>> CATHERINE: Hi, everyone. Thank you so much
for coming to our authors@talk today on the
Civil War as you should have collected it.
I'm very happy to introduce a very good friend
of mine, Christopher Oates. We went to college
and graduate school together. Chris graduated
magna cum laude from Brown with a degree in
political science and classics in 2007, earned
a master's degree in International Relations
from Oxford and he's currently working at
his PhD at Oxford. He's here now to talk to
you about the Civil War. In 2007, he published
his first book, Fighting for Home: The story
of Alfred K. Oates & the 5th Regiment. It's
also fabricated by his great, great, great
grandfather's experience in the Civil War.
Here is Chris Oates.
>> OATES: So thanks, Catherine. Thanks all
you guys for coming here, for taking time
out of your day. And I guess, if you're watching
this online. Thanks for, you know, procrastinating
with us. I'm here to tell you very quickly,
I've got about 45 minutes, the Civil War as
you should have learned it, I think you'll
find it as much more important thing than
you're ever were taught in school and I can
guarantee that you'll probably more entertained
than you're ever were in school. And I'm also--I'm
here also because I wanted to sell books.
I'll just lay-up my cards. I got some books
in the back, then, I've got a website fightingforhome.blogspot.com.
So, if you're watching this, there should
be a link over here, that little info box.
And the way it got started is that it is my--it's
largely based on letters from my great, great,
great grandfather. He came from England when
he was 12, signed up for the Union army when
he's 25, wrote a bunch of letters home, and
then about a hundred of those have been saved.
And when I was 11 years old, I can still remember
this. I was coming home from the battling
cages with my dad and I was telling him all
about the Civil War. I mostly read, like,
a book on it earlier that day. You know, how
kids are, like, they read something, they
start to tell everyone about it. Like, I mean,
a lot has changed in me since then. I don't
still talk about it. But, my dad had mentioned,
like, I think we have some Civil War stuff
at my sister's attic. And so, you know, yes,
we called her up and she came over and it
was like a black letter pouch, a hundred letters,
yellowed and laminated. And this is the book
that's in for 40 years. Here are some of the
letters that we think is Alfred Oates from
another thing we found in. This is I told
you, this amazing colorful letterheads, the
penmanship is incredible and then sitting
down to read this, these letters, the stories
in them were just fascinating. One letter
describes the execution of a number of deserters.
And you could just--you could feel them coming.
They're standing on their coffins so that
they just fall backwards into them when they
get shot. It talks about trading tobacco and
coffee with the Confederates across the river,
ball games and camps, and then--so, I was
reading these letters and I got interested
in the Civil War and over the next few years
I just kind of kept learning about the Civil
War. It's just a hobby. I would read books.
I would read a letter. He mentioned a battle;
I'd go get a book from a library about that
battle. And then, summer before my senior
year in high school, I just decided I was
going write a book on it. My logic was, "I'll
probably write a book on it someday, you know,
I shall do it now to get on my college application.
So, I started on it and it wasn't, you know,
it wasn't that good. It was like a dry military
history, and it was--it was okay. But then
I got to Brown University, I worked with a
professor and he's kept telling me, "You're
more Alfred Oates, more Alfred Oates." This
is the guy that's interesting. He is a compelling
character. So, I wrote that. So, it's the
possible appeal to, you know, history buff,
the unit he was in, the Excelsior Brigade
was one of the hardest fighting of the war.
One of the most famous at that time, but there
hasn't been anything written on that mid over
century. And if you're just a casual reader,
I think it's still a good story. It is a very
compelling character. What goes through is,
I think very interesting and I tried to set
it up so that each chapter is not a new topic,
a new theme. So, if you read it, you get some
sense of what it was like to be a soldier
fighting in the Civil War. Now, I came here
today and I'm saying that this is the Civil
War you should have learned it and find that
you didn't learn it the right way back in
high school. And I think that this is the
most misrepresented event in our nation's
history. And as I was reading about it and
learning about it for the purposes of the
book, I really came to believe that because
what I was learning about with the letters
and with the outside research I was doing
was not really what I learned in school. I
mean, even if you go to a great school and
you have a great history teacher, as I was
fortunate enough to do and that's--so that
my old teachers who's watching this online,
I want to say, you did a great job. But you're
still tied in the, you know, the curriculum
that the advance placement exam that helps,
you know, forces you into or suggest. You
probably had learned the social history of
the world. You know, how in fact the women,
blacks, immigrants, other groups, the political
histories of what President Lincoln did, what
Congress did, the Supreme Court, and maybe
the economic history, you know, how did it
affect the agricultural self, the industrialization
of the North, and innovated development of
the railroads, and if you're lucky some military
history battles in general and that sort of
thing. But you never get an understanding
of the central theme of the word. There's
never that, why was it fought? You know, what
is the over arching things that, you know,
besides just the battles and the social groups
and what the president did, what was the--what
was the reason why this country went to war
with itself? And I think it's misrepresented
and I say the most misrepresented in our nation's
history because we probably all think we know
that. We all ready--we think we know the answer
of why was the Civil War fought? Like, if
I ask you, you know, what was the reason for
the Civil War? When you think Civil War, what's
the one think you think about?
>> Slavery.
>> OATES: Absolutely wrong. It was not about
slavery. I mean, this is something that I
started to find in, you know, when I was reading
these letters, and I think it's understandable
that we all assumed it's about slavery because
it general divided free stage versus slave
stage. And when you're learning about history,
learn it chronologically. And slavery was
without a doubt the biggest political issue
in this country for the 40 years previously.
I mean, you're--you go to school and you learned,
you do the revolution and the constitution,
and then you start getting into crisis after
crisis about slavery. The Missouri compromised
in 1820 about how to we administrate, it should
be a free state of slave state, the Dred Scott
judgment as a slave of legal improperty of
a person, the Fugitive Slave Act, the Kansas-Nebraska
Act and then culminating with the Election
of 1860 when President Lincoln was elected
and during which slavery was the single biggest
issue. I mean, I would say, it's really the
only important issue in that presidential
election. So read all about those crisis,
and then you'd read about Civil War and this
is the only, it's got to be about slavery.
But I was--during my reading and was mentioned
in the book, there are couple examples that
indicate it wasn't at all about slavery. One
of the letter is from Alfred K. Oates and
he'd talked about the Emancipation Proclamation.
And that was a bill that Lincoln signed. It's
about two years into the war and it said that
all slaves in Confederate held territories
were now free. But Confederate held territories
are a very big quell of fact. So, slaves in
the slave state that had seceded: Maryland,
Delaware, Kentucky, Missouri were not affected.
Slaves in territory, already captured by the
Union, not affected. So, it was only directed
at the areas over which Lincoln had no direct
authority. So it was certainly a symbolic
victory for the anti-slavery movement and--but
it was designed as a military measure. If
you cut out the slave power of the South,
that's a large portion of their manpower.
Maybe some slaves will escape, maybe the South
working is hard and then you start to sap
the enemies right. So that's a big thing to
remember, the Emancipation Proclamation was
originally a military pleasure. And this is
what one soldier reflecting his friends wrote
home about it, "That bill that President Lincoln
passed has turned our patriotism. And if I
had my will, I would not fire my gun. If by
firing it would save the unit." We look on
the war with indifference and do not care
of one opinion. He was--he wanted to quit
the army when he found about the Emancipation
Proclamation. And that's a very paradoxical
thing when you realize that Alfred Oates was
very much against slavery. In all of his letters
he is negative about slavery as an institution.
The people who were connected with it on the
slave owning side, he is extremely negative.
So he calls one of the most the most hateful
men I've ever met, a man who used to catch
fugitive slaves as a living. And whenever
he mentions the slaves or free slaves, he's
very sympathetic. So, that they'll be thinking,
"Why is that
that an anti-slavery person who's fighting
in the Civil War which I always thought was
about slavery? Why does he want to quit and
go home and let the Union break up because
of the Emancipation Proclamation?" So, I did
some, some more reading and I started to understand
that you really need to understand the political
landscape of the times beyond just free state,
slave state. In the North, in the free states,
they did not like slavery, but they also did
not like abolitionist because abolitionist
or a very small fraction of the population,
they were getting slavery almost a single
minute league. Some might say obsessive league.
Most men in the North and men were the only
ones that could vote at that time. They worked
against slavery but they're also political
mavericks. So they thought, you know, let's
end this slavery but let's not do it right
away. Let's certainly not push our country
into a war over it. It's just not that important.
And they thought the abolitionist by storing
things up, by threatening, you know, immediate
abolition of slavery, they we're going to
alienate itself. And over the previous 40
years when those crises that I've mentioned
happened, the South had always made it clear,
"You try to abolish slavery, we might secede."
It wasn't in a direct threat but it would
just--they knew that was a possibility. And
the people in the North saw the abolitionist
and the secessionist as the same thing. They
were radicals who were staking out their positions
and who would drive the country to war rather
than lose their positions. So when the war
started there was a fear, I mean, I don't
think it was a big fear, but there was a sentiment
in the North that a concerned that this might
be an abolitionist plot, that this abolitionist
with Abraham Lincoln at their head forced
the South to secede, trigger--triggering a
war during which they would abolish slavery.
And in so doing have a hundreds of thousands
men who joined the army possibly died to further
their political agenda. And when the Emancipation
Proclamation came up, I believe that Alfred
Oates saw this and saw this is evidence that
that rumor was true. Now, he cools down a
couple of weeks afterwards, and I think once
they processed what it truly was they were
fine with it. But there was that fear and
just one other example and one chapter of
the book, it's event, a recruiting event in
New York City and it's one of my favorite
chapters because you're in a big political
hall and there's a rally and there's patriotic
speeches to get men to join up, and one man
stands up and he shouts of, "General, if you
will only get the president of the United
States to declare that this is not a war to
put down slavery in states where it exist,
you will get 500,000 men in the North implying
that this fear that's actually about slavery
is holding men back from joining up." I don't
think there was much truth of that because
Alfred Oates clearly had that fear but he
still joined up. But it said to me that it
certainly was not about slavery. It certainly
was about freeing the slaves. I mean, the
thought that millions of men would leave their
homes and risk their lives to free those they
never met. That's extreme selfishness, selflessness
that I've never seen in political history,
and it also wasn't about the institution of
slavery. So, that got me thinking, if it's
not about freeing the slaves, not even about
slavery, what could it possibly be? What could
be more important than the biggest political
issue of the previous 40 years? So, I read
it more and I, you know, study that to try
to find the South and I came across the quote
by Abraham Lincoln and I think some setup
perfectly. He says that, "A central idea pervading
this struggle is the necessity that is upon
us, of providing that popular government is
not an absurdity. We must settle this question
now, whether in a free government, the minority
have the right to break up the government
whenever they choose. If we fail it will go
far to prove the incapability of the people
to govern themselves." What was truly at stake
in the Civil War, at least from the Northern
perspective is the possibility that democracy
could actually work in the real world that
you could actually have a country without
a king or a czar or an emperor and it would
stay together because the fear--and this goes
back to the central dilemma of the constitutional
convention. I mean, do you think that your
history about the Constitution, all the checks
and balances that divide between the house
and the Senate, the legislative branch and
the presidential, the different election years
was all to try to figure out how to keep a
democracy stable so that some sort of mob
passion wouldn't overthrow it. So that some
dictator wouldn't come up but as I was saying
it wouldn't break up. Because what if there
is a big issue that people care passionately
about and thought, you know, for me this issue--and
majority want to do this without affecting
me badly. It's better for me to just lead
the country. And that had been a concern throughout
this time. I mean, the Whiskey Rebellion,
that was over--I believe it was alcohol taxes,
and the people pass the Appalachian Mountains
felt that it hurt them. They tried to have
a rebellion. George Washington put it town.
It was the only time when the president actually
fought the battle. There was a Shay's Rebellion
in Massachusetts over tax, New England actually
thought about secession during the war of
1812 where the state did not get heard in
their commerce. So the Civil war and the issue
of slavery as a political issue but not really
the cause was made that the Civil--made the
Civil war an example of whether democracy
could exist. I mean, democracy was not the--is
the main system of government at that time
in 1860. Most of the world was run by a king
or its part in the colony. France had actually
tried out the democracy twice and they tried
a republic two times, and both times ended
up with an [INDISTINCT] on the throne. So,
across the world, across Europe, all democratic
performers had a point to because a successful
democracy was the United States. Everyone
else would say, you know, if it won't work,
you can't work, you need that king. And so,
Lincoln saw the Civil War as the test of whether
a democracy could stick together because if
the South could succeed, the mid-west could,
New England could, the states could breakup
from each other and then maybe democracy would
fade away in certain states, and probably
it would fade away from the rest of the world.
So, I say that the Civil War is more important
than you ever imagined. Not to--not to say
that the issue of slavery was not important.
I mean, it affected millions of people and
the fact that it was abolished after the war
was, you know, huge impact on the war. But
in fact that the North won the Civil War and
proved that democracy could exist and could
actually work, I mean, that status—set the
stage for democracy to take over the rest
of the world. Most of the countries in the
world nowadays are democracies. And so, when
slavery affected millions, the Civil War is
a test of democracy affecting billions and
that's why I think it's important, but there
something else that we don't learn in school,
when we do the Socio-political Economic History,
and that's the fact that the people who live
through those times were real people. They
weren't just names of the book and I know
we--I mean, obviously we know that but knowing
it intellectually is a lot different from
actually kind of realizing with it something
from those people. And the Civil War just
as, I think slavery, the thought that we know
but it's about slavery hurts us from finding
the true story, I think the letters that we
do often see in public culture prevent us
from finding the full story because the typical
Civil War letter that you'll see on a documentary
or a T.V. show are generally the one with
the soldiers at a war and he's writing home
to his wife saying, why he's fighting, you
know, maybe he is scared of death but he hopes
to see his family and if he dies she knows
why he fought and knows why he believe so
much in this cause. And those were important
letters and the one that's in the Ken Burns
Documentary is an amazing one. I recommend
you all, you know, watch that documentary
but--and that's in the book as well, that
sort of thing. But it's not—they didn't
do—they didn't sit around talking for three
years every second of everyday about just
how patriotic they were and how willing to
die. I mean, that got a little repetitive
after a while. And we often don't get the
letters that show the full side of the war.
In fact that these people were patriotic,
had their own daily dramas or envisions or
opportunities that they tried to get, and
that's really what I tried to bring across
in the book. The fact that these soldiers
would fight a battle, many of them would die,
the survivors would not just, be thankful
that they're alive. But they would check the
newspapers to see what their media coverage
was. And some of the letters were, you know,
granting, you know, I can't believe the Hometown
Paper said, the 123 regiment fought, they
didn't have--their fingers were completely
clean. No gun powder on. We fought. We didn't
get a matching like, that sort of thing, the
daily life what actually goes on through these
men that are dismissed. And we get a very
narrow view of these soldiers did. So, for
the last 20 minutes of this talk, instead
of going a snapshot of what, you know, what
they did. I'm just going to tell you one story
and it's the first chapter of my book. In
my mind it's about the most interesting general
of the Civil War are—at least the most interesting
man who ever got the rank of general. And
the hope is that if you'll like the story,
you'll get the book because there's a lot
more in them. So, the man that I'm talking
about, his name is Daniel Edgar Sickles. And
there he is, a handsome man. And this guy
is, I mean, he is amazing. So, let's just
start, I'll go back, he was born on 1819.
His dad was a lawyer. So, middle class, his
family was descended from the Dutch that colonized
Manhattan. So, you know, solid middle class
maybe even upper middle class family. He was
apprenticed as a printer which is a very solid
member of society. The printers were often
viewed as the editors that were in newspapers
on those days. Attended what would become
New York University, NYU, and then was admitted
to the Bar in 1846. He started practicing
law before he passed the Bar exam. That's
going to be a trend you will find. They'll
be just a slight touch of corruption to it.
But he's an ambitious man, he is a, you know,
he is a charismatic man, and you could see
it from that photo, really he's a handsome
guy, nice mustache, and he gets started into
politics. He's ambitious and politics in New
York City in mid 1800 means Tammany Hall.
They controlled the Democratic Party and the
Democrats controlled the city. Now, whenever
you've ever heard about urban political corruption,
so graft, kickbacks, votes for favors, you
know, electoral fraud, Tammany Hall set the
gold standard for this. Nothing, nothing in
Chicago ever came close to what Tammany could
do and if you saw the movie, Gangs of New
York, the guy, I can't remember the actor's
name but he was the father in the Bridget
Jones movies. His character in The Gangs of
New York was a boss at Tammany Hall and they
show scenes and this actually happened, immigrants
would come off the boat they would get maybe
a roof over their heads, Tammany would help
them find the, you know, find the job and
all they ask in return that very time people
at Tammany where their votes on election day,
maybe their votes a few times, maybe the votes
of their friends, maybe the votes of their
recently deceased. If there was--if there
a name on the rolls Tammany was going to get
their vote. All the old political machines
operate the same ways, James Michael Curley
in Boston, Richard Daley the elder in Chicago.
Basically, it was the same thing but Tammany
was the best. They were the most outrageous.
So Dan Sickles joins Tammany Hall and he moves
up very quickly. And then you can see 1853
Council for the city, same year serves at
the Embassy in London. The ambassador at that
time would be, was James Buchanan. He was
the president before Lincoln. Then, New York
State Senate very quickly elected him as a
U.S. congressman, so very rapid rise. I mean,
he was an ambitious man, he was a talented
man, but he--wherever he went even in his
professional rise that took him from council
to congressman in four years scandals always
followed him. I mean he just couldn't get
away from them. First one is in his marriage,
and when your marriage is a scandal, you'll
know that it's something was going on. So
this is Teresa Bagioli, his wife. I don't
know which one is the more lifelike. I hope
for his sake it's the one in the right, he's
a handsome man. But he married Teresa in 1852
just before he came to be a city councilor.
That was a big scandal at stake. And she was
also a member of society. Her grandfather
had written the librettos for Mozart's operas.
Her father was a music teacher in New York
City and she actually grew up speaking five
languages. She's a very intelligent girl,
but the marriage was against the wishes of
both families. So it's a strange when you
think that families were very good family
friends. Sickles was a friend of her father
until the details started coming out. First
of all Teresa was pregnant at the time of
her marriage, probably the cause of the marriage.
Dan Sickles, well, he was 33 at that time
and Teresa was 16, and even in the 19th Century
that was not so great, even when they married
young. And then finally this is just a rumor
but I really had to say because with Dan Sickles
you never know, it was said that a couple
of years earlier Dan had had an affair with
Teresa's mother. So, you wouldn't be friends
with Dan Sickles afterwards. I mean, first
his wife and now his daughter. They got married
and they have a baby and Dan begins his political
career but again the scandals keep coming.
When he was a state senator he was censured
for bringing a prostitute under the floor
of the Senate. They were not allowed in the
tours. He then takes the same prostitute on
an official trip to England, presented her
to Queen Victoria and as a prostitute's name
gave the name of one of its political opponents.
I'll be honest, I've actually studied this,
I tried to figure out, you know, I did political
science what he was going for, I don't really
know. I think he was just him having fun with
his political opponent. He knew this story
was going to come up. But all of this is
the minor leagues for Dan Sickles. This is
just a warming up to one of the big scandals
of his life, The Philip Barton Key Affair.
I don't say it's the biggest because he later
was rumored to have had an affair of the Queen
of Spain as the ambassador but this was definitely
number two at least. So Dan Sickles at 1857,
he has won the election to Congress from as
a health representative from he New York State,
he travels down to Washington and immediately
comes in with that, you know, Washington society.
He is a charismatic man from the largest city
in the country and his wife is a beautiful
20-year-old, who speaks five languages, and
so, they go in and they get into society and
they make plenty of friends and Philip Barton
Key was one of them. He was a U.S. attorney
for the District of Columbia. His father wrote
the Star Spangled Banner and his uncle was
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court, so
a solid member of Washington society. He is
a handsome man, again, the mustache, back
in those days they were amazing. He and Dan
Sickles become really great friends even to
the point where Dan Sickles entrusts Philip
to take Teresa to all the balls and parties
that she has to attend whenever Dan Sickles
is busy either with, you know, official work
or, you know, a prostitute of his own. This
was not such a great idea because in--during
the winter of 1858 to 1859, this is after
Dan Sickles' has won reelection before he
was sworn in to his second term, Philip Barton
Key and Teresa begin an affair of their own,
soon to become the talk of the capital. Everyone
knows about it except for Dan Sickles. And
he can get the point where Philip Key rents
out a house on 15th Street, I think at the
northwest quadrant as a love nest for him
and Teresa and it was not in a very good part
of town and you could probably tell from this
drawing, you know, chick and dogs or something
but, you know, it's not a great section of
town but Philip Key rented it up and it was
just--it was the talk of Washington society.
That ends at late February just before Dan
Sickles is sworn into his second term. He
receives an anonymous note telling him of
the affair. He was in the House of Representative
at that time, he goes into the cloakroom,
brings the friend in who was the clerk and
he asks, "Is this true?" And he said, "It
is." And Dan Sickles was reported to be distraught
and actually weeping at this news. I mean,
whatever his own indiscretions, he did not
think that his wife would do this to him.
So, he goes home, he confronts Theresa, he
forces her two days later to write a confession.
A handwritten confession about what she did.
Some of the things just says, "I've been in
a house on 15th St. with Mr. Key, how many
times, I don't know." And then later, I've
written this with my bedroom door open and
my maid and child in the adjoining room and
bringing the child into it." Just to stress
the fact that Theresa was a mother and she
was having an affair. So, Sickles doesn't
know what to do. This actually—this letter,
just here it is, this was flashed on the cover
of Harper's Weekly later, the biggest newspaper
at that time. It was—it was the—one of
the few pieces of national media we had that
had a circulations of 200,000 each copy, and
you can assume it was passed around a number
of times. So, a sizable proportion of the
population read Theresa's confession, later
on. And the reason that just became a big
deal. The reason that Harper's Weekly eventually
got this is because the next day that came,
Dan Sickles is in his house, that's on Lafayette
Square, which is, you know, Washington D.C.
is right next to the White House. He was sitting
there and he had a couple of friends over,
political advisors, trying to fear or what
to do with this whole thing. And he looks
out the window, and who does he see but Philip
Barton Key. Key had a—we think had a rendezvous
with Theresa planned, she didn't show up.
She was, you know, locked in her bedroom with
her maid and her child. You know, she didn't
show up, he goes over to Lafayette Square.
And he's actually standing in the Square,
outside of their house with a white handkerchief,
signaling to Theresa to get her attention.
Dan Sickles sees this and whatever kind of
passionate nature he had that made him cry
when he heard about the affair. He just freaked
out. And he grabs two guns—three guns, two
Derringers and a revolver. He storms out of
the house. And Philip Key is a U.S. Attorney.
He is no downy. He sees Dan Sickles with the
guns, figures up the gig is up and he starts
running. Dan Sickles chases after him, through
Lafayette Square, I mean, shouting. One of
the things that, you know, he was afforded
to say, I don't know if this was a reconstruction
is, "Key, you scoundrel, you have disgraced
my home; you must die." He fires out. He grazes
him with his first shot. He fires out again.
He hits him—Philip Key in the groin. Key
is now on the ground on Lafayette Square.
He's crawling, he's actually begging for his
life against this madman, who's running at
him with a gun. Dan Sickles chases after on
him. And they think Key crawled to under a
tree. He was sitting there and kind of like
propped up and begging for his life. Dan Sickles
spot aims at him. He pulls the trigger, has
a misfire. Now, if it was a movie, maybe the
cops are rushing or he, you know, he comes
to his sense, or things, whatever. But, this
isn't a movie. So, he takes the next gun,
points at him, he pulls the trigger, boom.
Hits Philip Key in the chest as Dan Sickles
turns to go home. A United States Attorney,
his uncle's a Chief Justice, is bleeding to
death in Lafayette Park, in broad daylight
about 200 yards from the White House. So,
as you can imagine, Dan Sickles eventually
turns himself into the Attorney General. And
it becomes the biggest trial of the century.
And so, Harper's Weekly got the confession.
They also made a lithograph of what they assumed
to be the affair. I just want—I just want
to take one step at a time. I like this—yes,
like, the illustrator thought, "Oh I need
a passers by," So he has a guy, coolly, you
know—leaning by the spiked iron fence, just
leaning my elbow on just watching a dude get
murdered. You know, "Hi, honey, how was your
day?" "Oh, nice, I took a walk, and so, I
got to get murdered, no big deal. My elbows
are all thrown up." So, he came to trial,
the biggest trial of the year, or certainly
the biggest trial of the decade. Daniel Sickles,
United States Congressman killing a man in
broad daylight. But Dan Sickles, as I said,
he is ambitious. He's charismatic, and he
is not going to let a little thing like a
murder, you know, slow him up. So, he gets
as his lawyer, Edwin Stanton. One of the best
attorneys in the country later would be the
Secretary of War under Abraham Lincoln, so,
a very smart man. They devised a strategy.
First of all, they plead not guilty by means
of temporary insanity which was the first
in the American jurisprudence; they had never
had temporary insanity. But really what they
did was they realized this is a celebrity
trial, and so, they built it on character.
Dan Sickles, you know, he was only—he was
an outstanding man. He was defending his home,
he was defending his art. The real criminal
here was Philip Key, the evil Philip Key with
his house in the bad section of town tempting
the innocent Theresa from her marital bliss
into a life of sin. You know, that was the
real crime here. And so, they do this entire
trial and as you can see he's covered in the
media, I mean, people were following this
the—I'm sure, the arguments were printed
out in the newspapers of the day. And so,
the verdict comes, he's not guilty, of course.
And the verdict comes to a cheering courtroom,
who were all wildly in favor of Dan Sickles.
Now, he should have been at a peak of his
career right now. He was a nationally known
figure, very popular. He had defended his
home, you know, Victorian gentleman, defending
his honor. But then, he did something, I don't
think, Dan Sickles, the wily politician realized
what effects this would have. He made a mistake
right after the trial. Theresa came to him
and she asked for forgiveness. And he gave
it to her. And now, all of the sudden, the
coin turned because, Theresa, wasn't she the
one, who her sins had caused the man to die,
caused Sickles to go through this terrible
ordeal, caused New York one of their congressmen
for a large part of 1859. And all of the sudden,
I think, you know, Sickles or Tammany Hall,
or the folks at the district realized, you
know, if you take the people who are now,
have the audacity of forgiving his wife. The
people who still never got over the fact that
he killed a man, and then, those who just
didn't like him anyway. Dan Sickles was not
winning reelection. So, 1860 comes, he's not
reelected to another term. And when Dan—when
Abraham Lincoln comes into Washington in March
of 1861, Dan Sickles is on a train back to
New York City, he's in political exile. He's
a politician that no one—no one likes. But,
then something happens that I don't think
Sickles knew what [indistinct] this would
have, the Civil War happens. Now, the story
of how—I'm running out of time, a story
of how Dan Sickles became the General in Command
of Excelsior Brigade, the great stories, it's
in the book. I don't have time to say it now,
but it involves upstate New York versus New
York City, Democrats and Republicans in the
Senate, the State versus Federal Bureaucracy.
And it ends up with a scandal involving President
Lincoln, Mary Todd Lincoln, the White House
gardener and an undercover newspaper reporter
who had previously been a spy for England
and France. Or at least, that's, is involved
there—basically, the former spy was a kind
of the European version of Dan Sickles. Now,
that—the fact is that Dan Sickles, because
he was in exile had to do something big. When
the Civil War came along, he had to recruit
men—I mean, he's no longer a congressman
and what's the only thing really better than
being a congressman, and that's being a general.
So, he wanted to be a general. So, he puts
all of his efforts in 1861 into recruiting
man, later into the political battles to get
himself to command them. Now, I mentioned
this story and why it's part of the Civil
War that you should have learned. Because
the fact that this man was a politician and
ambitious, and that his career was ruined.
He is--I think 90% of why he recruited a brigade.
And he was a patriotic man, I think, that
comes through that he actually care about
the country, but he was also a very ambitious
man. And the brigade he formed, which my great,
great, great grandfather fought in. He fought
about 20 battles; they did very well, certainly
made many contributions to the Union war effort.
So, the fact that a murder trial impacted
5,000 men fighting for their country is something
that we don't learn. And something we don't
realize the daily dramas and ambitions that
are actually go into a national struggle like
the Civil War. But, and then, this is what
happened in the end, the Excelsior Brigade
was called after Dan Sickles, that a murderer
became kind of a patron of 5,000 Union soldiers.
But, I mentioned this not just because it's
an interesting story and I hope you had, you
know, enjoyed hearing but wanted to hear more
so you get my book. I say it because the two
parts of my talk today are connected. The
fact is, the Civil War is more important that
we ever thought about. And also it can be
more entertainment than we ever learned. And
I think, that's very—the connection between
them is very, very big because I read about
the Civil War. And I started in it because
of the letters I got from my ancestors. And
I read them because they were interesting.
And I kept reading them because they were
interesting. And so, to better figure them
out, I read more about the Civil War. I read
other books and I read, you know, the more
difficult books about the political and economic
situation. So, it was the fact that it was
entertaining that lead me to the importance.
I certainly—I would never have stayed with
it long enough to get to the understanding
of the Civil War democracy's testing ground
if it hadn't been for the letters I got and
for stories like this murder trial. And that's
something that we don't get in our history
classes, like, we're—we don't give the human
dramas, we don't give the entertaining value
that history can be. And so, we don't give
kids the incentive to keep on reading outside
of school. And obviously we can't do it for
every student for every era. But, if we start
to do it more and if we start to show them
why it can be fun to read about history, I
think that would lead them to understand why
it's important. And we'll lead them to things
that they wouldn't just get even if they got
a perfect on their AP exam. So, that is I
think the fact that entertainment and historical
importance to go together is the Civil War
as you should have learned it. And I'll take
any questions that you have. Yes.
>> Your thesis is that Civil War's about preserving
a national government that is, you know, not
like royalty or devolves into something where
the people split apart.
>> OATES: Right. I mean, certainly like other
factors were very important, but I think that's
the overall, okay.
>> The Internet, how much do you interpret
the last part of Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
where he says, "Government of the people,
by a people, for the people, shall not perish
from the earth." Do you have any comments
about that because I've always wondered what
the heck he really means by that? You can
interpret it as people, you know, on all of
the people versus just white people. But,
in terms of the national government, do you
have any feeling about what that means?
>> OATES: Oh, yeah, I just read that as an
understanding for the Constitution and the
Democratic System of Government which they
felt would fail if the Union as a unified
country failed. I mean, that's what I interpret
as, if the Union divides itself, the democracy
will start to perish, not just in American,
but across the world. I mean, I just saw this
as rhetoric, I didn't think it was anything
more. I might be wrong and I'm not sure.
>> Okay.
>> I can answer that it's because at the time
when you're asking about strong and if the
U.S. would really break up in half, it would
be vulnerable to foreign powers playing it
off the other, because foreign powers do not
understand democracy. And that's—that's
when Lincoln had--I'm glad you brought up
the Gettysburg Address because I can't totally
agree with the thesis you made. And there's
two points I disagree with. The first is,
you said that you sort of discovered the study
in the letters that a lot of people were more
focused on preserving democracy rather than
eliminating slavery. But, that's not anything
buried at all, it is the—it's the meat of
the Gettysburg address. I mean, that is the
thesis that Lincoln talks about. I don't believe
he mentioned slavery in the Gettysburg address.
>> OATES: Right.
>> It was very overt.
>> OATES: That's what you learn about in school,
you often learn slavery as the Civil War that
was I was talking about.
>> Well, that's the second part of the disagreement
I had with you, I mean, I feel like I'm the
only one who still thinks the Civil War was
about slavery. Every time people comment on
the Civil War in the media, they're always
saying that, "Oh, the conventional wisdom
is—it was about slavery, but actually it
wasn't," actually, everybody says that. This
is what I hear all commentators about the
Civil War say. In my opinion, the only way
you can accept this thesis is you can just
ignore all the evidences that speaks against
it. Look at the declarations of Independence
of the individual states. Look at what they
said, their reasons for seceding in the war,
they were very overt, they wanted to establish
a white supremacist state, that's what they
have wrote. And also about democracy, the
Confederation was also a democracy, actually.
It was not, though, they were not nominating
a king.
>> OATES: Well, on that—I'm not, I mean,
I'm not an expert on the stuff. I know that
slavery was much more important to them. I
only thought slavery in the South as the issue
that led into what they thought is a perceived
political disenfranchisement. I think for
them, the election of Lincoln, they already
were in the minority in the House. They, I
think, were the minority in the Senate and
now, they lost—the president was against
slavery. I thought for them slavery was the
issue that shows from here on out, the South
was going to be voted down time and again
in Washington. So, it's better for them to
get out of the country so they can have as
say, yeah.
>> I think the two different things are being
said here. On the one hand, it's certainly
true that the South seceded because they wanted
to maintain slavery. I mean, after the jury
stopped the decision, there were people in
the South saying, "Oh, we're going to open
a slave market on Boston Commons." So, they
envision not only having slavery, but it's
sending them into the North. I think, it's
also valid to say this especially based on
the letters that you have. And the comments
about people riding it at the time, that the
majority of the people in the North did not
see the fight as being about slavery, they
were uncomfortable with that. Okay, a lot
of them saw the fight as not necessarily being
about slavery, or limiting slavery as being
about preserving the Union. I mean, and Lincoln
certainly did not go into office saying I'm
going to eliminate slavery. So, you have to
be clear that it's not that the North stood
up and said, "We're not going to get rid of
the slavery and stop this." And thereby stop
the South, it's more Lincoln said, "We're
going to preserve the Union and the South
gave us the reason for winning, we're going
to maintain slavery." So, it's a—I think
the premise that it's a lot more complicated
than saying somebody in the North decided
it's time to get rid of slavery.
>> That's a good premise.
>> OATES: And what you said about slavery
being a very big issue for the South, I think,
I mean,-it's that actually true that it was.
What Lincoln was talking about, I think, is
that there are always going to be very important
issues to groups of people. You know, you
have to make sure in a democracy for it to
last that even if folks that lose out on a
specific issue don't leave the country because,
I mean, as I've said in New England almost
you see, they talked about secession during
the war of 1812 which they felt hurt commerce
with Britain because we were at war with Britain.
And so, you know, it was hurting their interests.
So, I think it was that at any given point
in time, there's going to be a big issue,
maybe not only it's because of bigots and
slavery again. And I certainly think slavery's
is why it was between the states that was
in 1860. But, for Lincoln it was about the
general idea that even a political issue can't—doesn't
divide a country—into two different countries.
>> I think you see it's like today with the
Healthcare debate too. I mean, I think a lot
of people react to, you know, like the imposition
of some sort of healthcare program as even
though, a president was elected. The—it's
still some, some sort of aggravation of democracy.
And it's an important issue and people feel
that because their voices isn't the one that's
being represented that democracy is somehow
being sacrificed, not counting on the validity
of that position at all. I think it's not
something that's gone away. This sense that,
you know, like this is so important to me
that, you know, screw democracy.
>> OATES: I mean, it's—a lot of democracies
have split up, I mean, Yugoslavia's is split
up over, it wasn't a democracy, but you know,
a lot of countries has split up over specific
issues. So yet, it's not unlikely but it might
happen.
>> Yeah, well, I mean democracy is a corrupted
republic, anyway. I mean, if you look at—if
you look at [INDISTINCT] of government, I
mean, it's actually, essentially the majority
rule, it's not really the kind of thing that
you want, it's mob rule.
>> Yes, two walls and a sheet voting on what's
for dinner.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> OATES: Are you—are you, you're right.
I mean, back in that time they talked much
more in terms of the Republic and preserving
the Republic. Nowadays, they talk about democracy.
And we have implicitly the idea of checks
and balances. So that's why, I use the term
of majority rules because that's what, you
know, that we think of.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, they did, Lincoln talked about preserving
the Republic and preserving popular government.
He didn't even ever use the term democracy.
>> I supposed it devolved into a healthcare
debate, I don't know.
>> No, I—I think you've made an excellent
point, though, because it's the whole thing
is very complex and you can't simply say that
it is slavery and you can't simply say that
it isn't. I mean, I thought about this a lot
and I think, you know, if slavery had not
been an issue, there might not have been any
other issue newly to divide the section of
states. On the other hand, it was—how are
we going to resolve this that was the primary
cause in the Civil War. A lot of people thought,
okay, is where do we miss because they want
to preserve the Union and then they eventually
changed the scene and that this was a way
of getting beyond the usual slavery routes
and all those things that's been happening
all over the country. And that there's still
the debate, you know, nobody's going to be
able to answer something especially since
none of the people that moved to the Union
at the time are alive anymore.
>> In your research, did you find another—and
I always thought that it was about slavery,
but not in terms of the normal good or bad
in that kind of system, and that the North
was winning over the South because they were
more powerful. And then they secede because
they thought they were going to lose their
economic place. And then they got rid of slavery
with the votes that describes this outcome.
>> OATES: I mean, that's probably wasn't important.
I never—I never came across that. I came
across the South thinking with slavery, you
need to expand westward or else it will eventually,
you know, wither and die, I think that's the
term they used in the North, not wanting to
let it to expand westward. And that was—that
was actually the main debate in the election
that Lincoln was voted. Whether slavery would
expand westward and he came down and I know
it's not going to expand at all. And those
in the South were against--very much against
Lincoln, thought, well, he won't let it expand
west. Next thing he's going to do is eliminate
where it already exists, and that's why the
man that stood up at the political rally said,
get Lincoln to say it's not about putting
slavery where it already exists. I think,
most of people in the North would agree that
it shouldn't expand—that's why they voted
for Lincoln, but they weren't about to start
a war to put it down where it already was.
>> And was their main reason for why the North
didn't want it to expand?
>> OATES: I think the idea of the frontier
was very important back then, the fact that,
you know, it gets too crowded in the east,
a man can always go-- a white man, can always
go west and find new land. And that you have
slavery in the west. Then, you have the system
of planting crop or an aristocrat with thousands
of slaves taking off the land from the humbled,
you know, middle class white men, who would
have had that.
>> I think that's a good point too, I mean,
it's—the whole dynamic as west versus east
as much as it is North versus South. I mean,
Lincoln represented the west. The Republicans
represented the west, I mean, the first Republican
candidate was John Freemont, who was a Californian.
So, it's more of the attitude of the westerners,
which in those days with people from Iowa
and Minnesota and things like that who said,
"We want to have the life out, life further
west would be the same as what we have."
>> Well, I learned that at school, it sounded
like that and the other side of it was that
it was a more of a conservative thing, a little
more, and if they lost control of the South
and the South getting trade with Europe and
that sort of thing.
>> OATES: I mean.
>> Would be much worse than abolition.
>> In Atlanta?
>> Yes.
>> OATES: If the Europe is a big part. British,
I go to school in Britain. So I've read, you
know, their history textbooks, occasionally.
They wanted to establish an informal empire
in the South like what they had in Latin America
at that time, where very favorable trade treaties
that they were basically dictating. They tried
to do it in the South, but they were defeated
by the political power of Washington. And
so, that maybe true, but the Southern tried,
you know, to put on the trade. And that's
actually the way the North beat them was to
cut off the Southern trade routes. That's
actually why cotton is grown in Egypt today
because the Brits couldn't get cotton from
the South, so they planted it in Egypt where
they already had a colony. So, that is one
of the reasons why the South was much very
poor after the war is that their main commodity,
they have lost the market on it. And that
might be why those people in Atlanta are still
bitter about it.
>> Oh, thank you, Chris. This has been great.
>> I have one more question. Does your book
attempt to explain what the heck General Sickles
was doing on the second day at Gettysburg?
>> OATES: Sort of not really. Basically, in
Gettysburg, the Union was—it was called
a fish hook, so, basically with one big line,
Dan Sickles was at the end. He marched out
pretty far. And that's what got attacked and
got driven back in and if it wasn't for the
fighting on the Round Top which is in the
movie, Gettysburg, with Joshua Chamberlain,
they say the Union might have lost Gettysburg.
The previous battle to that which was Chancellorsville,
Dan Sickles had the experience of being in
the low ground, and having the Confederates
fighting by the high ground in front them.
And then, just shell him, you know, shell
his lines to pieces and that bit of the Gettysburg
ground. He was in the low bit, the whole line
was supposed to be on a ridge, but where Sickles
was the ridge kind of died out. And in front
of him was very high ground. He was afraid
that the same thing would happen. The Confederates
just walked up, get the high ground, shoot
him and then, go. So, he took the high ground,
extending his lines directly contradicting
an order from a superior. But, he later claimed
that by taking it even though his line was
shattered and pushed back, he brought enough
time for the Union to form troops, and that
if he had been pushed back to his original
position, and he would have been pushed back
into defeat. So, I don't—I don't know if
that's true. Yeah, I think it's more on someone,
so. But, that's—yeah, it's mentioned in
the book.
>> I've finished reading the book compares
to the Two Players in the Attic, I don't know
if you...
>> OATES: I've heard of it.
>> But, it's a good [INDISTINCT] modern perception,
and so, probably of Civil War veteran perception.
I'm wondering, how do you perceive Civil War
reenactment through the light of this novel,
what's up with this novel?
>> OATES: I guess, I did I saw some books
of Civil War reenactments. And you first,
you kind of think these guys are weird because
they're dressing up, and they're shooting
up guns. But then you go there and you're
like, they get to dress up and shoot up guns.
So, it's really cool, actually. I recommend
you guys like attend one. It's actually a
lot of fun. I don't—I don't really, I can't
go into like an analysis of that, I haven't
spent enough time, but...
>> I mean, it's just only...
>> OATES: I just think it's kind of an interesting
hobby that I have. And you know, it's better
than sitting around watching TV, so why not.
And they also buy a lot of books. I really—I
really like you guys.
>> I agree.
>> Thank you so much.
>> OATES: Thank you.